ein pubertätsblocker was ist das
eigentlich das ist ein Medikament dass
die Pubertät bei Jugendlichen verhindert
diese Präparate die sind heftig in der
Diskussion weil sie plötzlich irgendwie
in Mode kommen ja und zwar von Menschen
die damit werben dass sich doch jedes
Kind seinen Geschlecht einfach aussuchen
können ja und jetzt das auch mit dem
Logo des
Bundesfamilienministeriums also mit dem
Stempel der Bundesregierung ist für
solche pubertätsblocker geworben worden
du bist noch jung und bist noch nicht in
der Pubertät dann kannst du
pubertätsblocker nehmen so hast du mehr
Zeit zum Nachdenken und du kannst in
Ruhe überlegen welcher Körper passt zu
mir
mit offiziellem Logo und aus
Steuergeldern finanziert wendet sich das
Bundesfamilienministerium im Internet an
Kinder die merken ich bin gar kein
Mädchen oder ich bin gar kein Junge und
dies ohne Hinweis auf die erheblichen
Risiken Nebenwirkungen und Folgen vor
denen mediziner warnen
pubertätsblocker einfach pauschal zu
empfehlen halte ich für falsch das sind
sehr starke Mittel in der Regel Hormone
die sich nicht nur auf die Ausbildung
der sekundären Geschlechtsmerkmale
auswirken sondern das gesamte Wachstum
beeinträchtigen können und weiter man
greift in den regulären
wachstumsrhythmus ein was ein harter
Einschnitt ist Bild fragt der
Ministerium nach ob solche
verharmlosenden Tipps der persönlichen
Meinung der Ministerin entsprechen keine
direkte Antwort stattdessen der Hinweis
dass die Redaktion des regenbogenportals
inhaltlich eigenständig arbeitet nur
eben mit Logo des Ministeriums seltsam
auch das Ministerium bestreitet die
Empfehlung von pubertätsblockern
man Regel lediglich an sich tiefergehend
beraten zu lassen kurze Zeit später ist
der entsprechende Beitrag auf der
Website des Ministeriums dann nicht mehr
zu finden dieser wurde wohl gelöscht
ja die Berichterstattung von Bild die
hat also Wirkung gezeigt dass
Familienministerium das hat noch am
Abend reagiert die Webseite mit dieser
Werbung für pubertätsblocker die war
stundenlang nicht erreichbar haben wir
eben gesehen denn sie wurde überarbeitet
und zwar an einer ganz entscheidenden
Stelle ja der stand erst so nämlich mit
den Fragen bist du noch sehr jung
richtet sie also direkt an Jugendliche
und bist du noch nicht in der Pubertät
dann kannst du pubertätsblocker nehmen
so stand es da erst und dann wurde diese
Passage ausgetauscht und dann gab es
eben den Hinweis auf einen Arzt oder ein
Ärztin also bitte die Fragen da
wenigstens das Besprechen darüber mit
CDU-Präsidiumsmitglied Julia Klöckner
hierbei Bild live grüße Sie Frau
Klöckner wie kann man überhaupt auf so
eine Idee kommen vom Familienministerium
unterstützt diese Website und da wird
man dann ganz offen für diese Blogger
hallo guten Tag wir waren auch entsetzt
es kann doch nicht sein dass mit einem
bundesregierungslogo Kinder wirklich
ganz junge Leute angesprochen werden und
pubertätsblocker wieso
Hustenbonbons empfohlen werden und
deshalb haben wir das auch kritisiert
haben das auch zum Thema gemacht sie
kennen das was dann im Internet passiert
ist einem unterstellt wird man sei gegen
Transpersonen das ist Quatsch aber es
kann nicht sein dass das ein
Freifahrtschein ist dass jeder unter
einem Logo der Bundesregierung plötzlich
schreiben kann was er will das ist ein
Eingriff in die Entwicklung eines Kindes
und das junge Menschen unsicher sind
gerade wenn einem noch solche subtilen
Fragen gestellt werden das ist nicht
anständig wenn man so vorgeht und noch
einmal hier geht es auch um medizinische
Folgewirkungen und deshalb ist der
Hinweis auf die Konsultation eines
Arztes absolut dringend geboten
aber reicht das diese Überarbeitung das
jetzt eben nur noch der Hinweis kommt na
gut das müssen Sie jetzt vielleicht noch
mal mit dem Arzt besprechen trotzdem
wird ja weiter sozusagen für diese
pubertätsblocker in irgendeiner Form
geworben und das eben mit dem Stempel
unserer Bundesregierung da muss noch
mehr passieren so eine Überarbeitung
reicht doch eigentlich nicht
ja das muss natürlich zum Thema im
entsprechenden Ausschuss gemacht werden
und es kann nicht sein dass
Kinder das Familien in so eine
Unsicherheit auch entlassen werden und
das mit dem Logo der Bundesregierung es
gibt Menschen es gibt sicherlich auch
junge Menschen die sich fragen
wer bin ich eigentlich und wie ist es
mit meinem Geschlecht fühle ich mich
wohl in meinem Körper ja aber das zu
einer Ansprache so unkoordiniert zu
machen wie das auf dieser Seite ist es
ist ja quasi eine Werbung dafür und ganz
offen ein pubertäts Blogger das heißt ja
auch dass meine körperliche Entwicklung
dermaßen auch beeinträchtigt ist oder
auch die Empfehlungen Hormone zu nehmen
das ist so eine lapidare Erwähnung
ohne die Folge auch abzuschätzen was das
vielleicht mit Kindern mit Jugendlichen
macht die das lesen also dieses dann
so banal anzubieten wird dem Thema nicht
gerecht sind Sie der Auffassung dass
Kinder bzw Jugendliche ihr Geschlecht
frei wählen können
Kinder sind da doch überfordert Kinder
haben unglaublich viele Fragen sind sehr
beeinflussbar dass man reinhören muss
dass man das auch eine Entscheidung ob
zum Beispiel jemand sein Geschlecht auch
operativ umwandeln will weil er wirklich
nach einem ganz langen
Entscheidungsprozess und
Beratungsprozess diesen Weg dann geht
das ist ja nicht etwas was man von heute
auf morgen entscheidet aber es wird
jetzt durch die Bundesregierung so
banalisiert das ist im Grunde überhaupt
keine Geschlechter gibt und wenn Sie
heute äußern dass man von zwei
biologischen Geschlechtern ausgeht von
Mann und Frau und dass man sich durchaus
in einem anderen Körper oder falsch
fühlt keine Frage und das ist auch
Transpersonen gibt aber das ist ja
mittlerweile keine Debatte oder offene
Diskussion mehr sondern das ist so eine
gesinnungsdebatte geworden deswegen
nochmal ganz kurz
einhake weil sie ist gerade aufgebracht
haben von wie viel Geschlechtern gehen
sie aus von zweien oder von mehreren
oder
wie würden Sie die Frage beantworten
also ich halte mich da ich halte mich da
an die Wissenschaft ich bin nämlich
keine Biologin und was Biologen und auch
nur bei Preisträgerinnen sagen ist dass
es zwei biologische Geschlechter gibt
aber das ist durchaus
das Phänomen auch gibt und auch dass das
was Menschen auch umtreibt das muss man
auch ernst nehmen dass sie sich in ihrem
Körper nicht richtig fühlen dass sie
Transpersonen sind aber jetzt alles über
Bord zu werfen und alle anderen als
reaktionär hielten hinterwäldlerisch
anzusehen die davon sprechen das ist
Mann und Frau gibt und ich finde diese
Debatte muss offener geführt werden
respektvoller geführt werden und nicht
sofort unterstellt werden man sei gegen
transperson das ist falsch so etwas man
will Menschen dann auch häufig mundtot
machen und noch einmal zu ihrer
Ursprungsfrage was Kinder und
Jugendliche angeht wenn man Kindern sagt
es könnte sein du hast gar nicht das
Geschlecht dass du in dem du geboren
bist mit dem du geboren bist
überlegen Sie doch mal was mit Kindern
dann passiert und wenn sie dann auch
noch regelmäßig das Geschlecht neu
definieren können ich glaube nicht dass
man jemanden da mehr zu mehr Identität
und Selbstbewusstsein verhilft im
Gegenteil
Frau Klöckner sie kritisieren die andere
Regierung nicht nur in diesem Fall
sondern auch für Ihre aktuelle Politik
sie werfen ihr tatsächlich
Verantwortungslosigkeit vor warum genau
erklären Sie uns das noch mal
jetzt bezogen auf die aktuelle Energie-
ja schauen wir uns an der Krieg der
russische Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine
ist ja nicht vorgestern oder vergangenen
Monat geschehen sondern bereits im
Februar und das sind viele Monate bis
Oktober und es ist bis dato nicht
wirklich etwas strukturelles Geschehen
es sind zwei Energiekosten
dämpfungsprogramme aufgelegt worden aber
sage und schreibe nur 29 Unternehmen
haben eine positive Zusage zu ihrem
Antrag bekommen das ist peinlich und das
ist lächerlich da kommt keine Hilfe an
und der zweite Punkt ist es wurde eine
Kommission eingesetzt sogenannte
gaspreiskommission die hatte nur wenige
Tage
übrig um oder nur wenige Tage Zeit um
ein Vorschlag unter Zeitdruck zu machen
was gar nicht passgenau sein kann und da
sage ich das ist eine Auslagerung in
Outsourcing von Verantwortung auf eine
Kommission die unter Zeitdruck arbeiten
musste wir werden gerne als Opposition
das haben wir Angeboten in im
Sommerpause zu einer Sondersitzung
hierher gekommen und ist eigentlich
ziemlich klar was man machen muss die
Angebotsseite erweitern damit der
Energiepreis auch sinkt mehr
Kernkraftwerke laufen lassen ich bin
sehr erstaunt dass die Grünen die er
sich als sogenannte klimaschutzpartei
auch in Szene setzen dass die Grünen
jetzt Schweröl verbrennen lassen dass
sie wirklich auch solche
CO2-Schleudern lieber zulassen und
fördern als dass sie Kernkraft länger
laufen lassen und wenn ich das noch
sagen darf die Stromsteuer die könnte
jetzt ohne dass man in Europa jetzt ein
großes Verfahren anstrengen müsste auf
das europäische Mindestmaß runter senken
das sind alles Hilfen die hätten schon
längst laufen können und deshalb dieses
abwarten dieses Zögern dieses
diskutieren sich anschauen die Zeit
haben die Leute nicht davon können die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger und die
Unternehmen nicht ihre Rechnungen zahlen
die cdu-spitzenfrau Julia Klöckner
[Musik]